was wir als Demokratie finde ich
ernsthaft verpasst haben ist dem ein
eigenes emotionales Angebot
entgegenzusetzen du bist gut weil du
gebraucht wirst du bist gut weil du was
bewegen
kannst ja natürlich wir sehen doch
gerade ne wir sehen Umbruchphasen das
haben wir gerade besprochen hier wir
sehen wie sich die Demokratien behaupten
müssen international unbruchfasen sind
für viele Menschen mit Ängsten
beschäftigt diese unbruchfasen sind für
viele Menschen mit Unsicherheiten
behaftet und ich glaube dass auf diese
Unsicherheiten die Rechten eine sehr
einfache Antwort haben und das ist die
anderen sind schuld die da draußen den
Schuld und wir verteidigen dich gegen
die ich glaube nicht dass wir jetzt
Demokraten richtig damit fahren dem
einfach hinterherzaufen tut ja gerade
zum Glück auch wir nicht in der Ampel
aber was man tatsächlich tun muss ist
den Leuten eigenes Angebot für
Sicherheit zu geben und auch ein
Zugehörigkeitsgefühl nicht über
Abgrenzung nach außen oder nach oben
sondern über wir kriegen das zusammen
hin